[Applause]
who is the greatest athlete you've ever
worked with
i wanted to ask that who's the one that
like
when you said whenever we got hard
you're like we're gonna drop the hammer
who's the one that like
drops the hammer every [ __ ] time
don't even have to worry about it this
is this guy's a
dog yeah i mean it comes down
it's hard to call because you don't want
to pick favorites right like it would
come down to
it would come down second to brandon
marshall brandon marshall number one
right so we're gonna shout out to shout
out to the boss
so there's different categories of
athleticism right right so
it's hard because there's what you see
and like what's given to you so this
idea of epigenetics
i i know i'm being super evasive to try
and avoid picking just one
but there are give us your top five i'll
give you my top five athletes
of all time and take the personal away
from it okay good uh
pre-fontaine ooh mid distance runner
right that's here that's the athleticism
like yeah he's
you know what he's akash to the nth
degree
okay this guy's he's laying it out for
him akash is like he literally like i'll
hear him say like
yo don't be a [ __ ] yeah like to himself
does akash empty the tank the most out
of anyone here yeah he's got the most
approved
yo in my dms because we put up a poll we
went to the people everybody's like
everyone and not even that people
followed up like yeah i was like yo
akash for sure he's got more to prove
akash is laying out a hundred percent
off yeah
yeah so it's a little good story but
it's i love it pre-fontaine for sure
really but he never won at the biggest
level dude to to because my biggest
thing is like
the passion that he pursued that with
right yeah the best pace is a suicide
pace and today feels like a good day to
die
yeah that's fine you're running on a
you're doing foot nascar like what are
you talking about that's
amazing to be able to be like yo you're
going to beat me but you're going to
have to bleed to do it
yeah that's what i'm after do any of
these guys train the mental like do they
do meditation and higher oh that's a
huge part
one of the big things that health like a
house of athlete on wednesdays
no one's really training and that's a
cool thing that brandon's done so like
shout out house of athlete and brandon
marshall
um is they do literally do like mental
fitness classes where they
they'll do group sessions like therapy
is a big part of what they do sports
psychology is huge
that's awesome yeah and i mean you see
it i mean at the at the olympic level
like norway usually comes in
out of the woodwork in the winter
olympics and just waxes everyone
they send the most amount of sports
psychologists out of any other country
right any other country for any other
whether it's summer or winter
and they're just coming out and yeah
that's huge the mental aspect is huge
which is for me and
why i think pre is my favorite is
because that's what i value in athletics
because when i see someone who's like yo
i want to take it there like yeah that's
what i want
because there's an epigenetic expression
which like epigenetics is this word that
basically means like
your your genetic makeup your height
your weight your
propensity to put on muscle your
coordination all of this that's a bullet
in the chamber
but your training pulls the trigger now
there's some people that are all
triggered
that have no god given like a mugsy
bones just like you know you're five
six yeah and he's still getting up like
that's
what five three was he five three yeah
that's amazing to me because that's like
that's a here thing yeah right so but
like there's some people
the epigenetic expression of like just
their makeup
like i would put christian mccaffrey up
there oh wow okay and here's and but
here's why right so christian was
in my first year at stanford christian
was there and i think it was his draft
year
and christian if i'm not mistaken hit 10
reps on the 225 bench
some people value strength as paramount
in athleticism and they would look at
that and be like oh you're entering into
the league you're coming in with a 225
for 10 bench and like there weren't
great reps
watch that guy on a track you watch him
bound and doing some
single leg work he's a [ __ ] gazelle
right and his
his acuity for the game the ability to
navigate these spaces and like avoid
avoid people and like he's just so so
that aspect of athleticism
so in a lot of ways like his head was a
beast too
crazy but that's that's the epigenetic
thing right so there's
there's a bullet in that chamber yeah
someone's pulling the trigger
okay that's the perfect storm so those
two um
lance lance payne have any idea how
painful what he did
is yeah like any idea like losing that
nut or
what well not even that obviously that
the fact like you we go on the you guys
were bitching about the assault bike
earlier yeah
five minutes yeah this guy is [ __ ]
yeah
what he's doing he's here his gears
he also took him you can switch the gear
down i'll make it easier pedal he does
not it doesn't matter
dude so here's the thing and there's
wind cyclists
cyclists are like the og like before
[ __ ] baseball
cyclists dude there was a guy back in
like the 80s or 90s his name was bjorn
reese he was blood doping so hard that
his
hematocrit was well over 60. the
equivalent of like having ketchup in
your vans
his blood was so thick to carry so much
oxygen to
that much more efficient like to give
contacts most people
males hematocrit levels are at 48 so
it's essentially your
oxygen carrying capacity the amount of
red blood cells you have in your plasma
so it's like 48 of your blood is for
most people for most males yeah
like red blood cells that carry oxygen
yeah so it's like well if we had more of
those we could carry more oxygen and we
could probably go further
this guy just doped it and brought it up
to 60
60 which is insane like the guy and when
you're light on blood what happens are
you more irritable like
um no i mean you're just way less
efficient if you're
an inefficient at carrying oxygen i know
exactly where you're going with this
[Laughter]
they're the opposite of doping like if
you're on a bike trip and they're losing
blood i mean this is
you know they're bloodletting they're
letting no they're blood blooding
they're letting it like having leeches
it is yeah lance armstrong pain they can
take pain though
right but but landsat can handle pain
okay so right now
wait the pain is cycling or the blood
dopamine or both the cycling the cycling
well if anything and here's an
interesting thing to think about
first of all i love this that they're
all white guys so far this is amazing
i hope for us as athletes
okay tyson tyson kind of going back to
the mental side
yeah like the fact that he could and i
totally believe this beat his opponent
before the
before the bella yeah yeah and then when
he looks across and they break eye
contact no
maybe here's my tyson moment i forget
who he was fighting
when he came out with the hotel towel on
we cut the hole in the hotel would you
remember that
oh yeah that to me because that's that's
the reduced essence of sport
yeah and then in a sport that is so
overrun
especially now with like extravagant
logan where the [ __ ] is yeah
the other guy yeah and then this yeah
it's getting crazy
but there's the reduced essence of like
when he had that quote it's like
i'm gonna eat your children yeah
remember that yeah yeah yeah
against lewis that's amazing so who do
we got we got mccaffrey
preak lance tyson
gotta go bowl yeah i think hussein man
well so here's
bolt is always an interesting thing to
me because he is such uh
like a functional anatomy and
biomechanical anomaly
right because he's so tall and his
ability to go
just straight rather than side to side
we were talking about this last night
right if you look at the world record
sprinters prior
to when bolt came around and assaulted
powell is pretty tall
as far as printers go he's like six
three but the last 25 world records
five eleventh yeah because it's a good
balance of have being
stable and also having a decent stride
length right if i'm shorter
i have less deviation of a center of
mass i'm super stable but my stride
length might not be that big so
but if i'm super tall i'm on taco fall
i'm coming in at like seven five
yeah i'm wobbling all over i'm wobbling
all over the place right so it's like a
performance exists in a vacuum taco fall
100 meters gold medal all day
no one in the universe could touch you
because you run it like 14 steps
yeah even both at 6'5 runs 41 strides in
100 meters
right and most people are running 44 45.
he's able to maximize that stride like
he's not moving side to side which is a
crazy thing most
paul guys will start to shift laterally
as they run
right but he can keep it on the track
and even i think more impressive than
his 100 958 is his 219 19
right because he's got to go around that
bank track where now that displacement
of that center of mass
across that greater distance he's on one
leg
is much more difficult to withstand so
when he comes out of that like
that corner like [ __ ] paladin knights
and he just slingshots past
everyone that to me is probably from a
pure
like um force production standpoint his
ability to create tremendous amounts of
like ground contact unparalleled i think
we'll never see an athlete in that
in that subsection of athleticism we'll
never see an athlete like him again in
our life
you